so now we're going to move into
discussing some relaxations of
differential privacy the first one
epsilon delta differential privacy is
sometimes referred to simply as relaxed
privacy so what what is it and how does
it compare to our previous definition
this is the change so we have our
multiplicative requirement but we have
this little escape hatch over here
that's all typically we assume we are
interested in this for the case that
Delta is sort of cryptographically small
so Delta is very tiny which should be
very tiny so our original definition of
differential privacy is just epsilon
zero differential privacy we just set
Delta Delta 20 to get rid of that term
okay good so now I want to define the
privacy loss random variable so it has
some icky notation we have a pair of
adjacent data sets x and y and we think
about what happens when we run em on
input X and we look at remember I have
fixed to x and y so we look at for the
output that's produced when the database
is X the log of this ratio that's going
to be our privacy loss random variable
with respect to Y when we're running on
X and we sample this privacy locks
random variable as they said by run em
of X to obtain X I and then output at
quantity right privacy law surrounding
variable
with that in mind we can say that
epsilon Delta differential privacy
promises that with probability 1 minus
Delta the privacy loss will be at most
Epsilon this is not really obvious from
the definition and it requires proof we
won't go through the proof today so why
do we care about this what do we gain
from this relaxation when we gain many
things for example we will see better
composition bounce than we had before we
can use cryptography to simulate a
trusted center where the escape hatch
Delta is going to be the probability
that the adversary breaks the crypto
system for example you can prove that in
the two-party case for differential
privacy which has to be defined but
basically one party has a value a and
the other one has a value B and they're
trying to compute some function of a and
B you can prove that cryptography lets
you provably achieve better accuracy in
the to privacy case or rather epsilon
Delta gives you better accuracy than
epsilon zero you can live with perhaps
some tiny cryptographically small
probability of a complete privacy breach
and they said this like little escape
hatch and that lets you do some things
that you couldn't otherwise do and
finally we were talking about adding
Laplace noise for our rear value real
valued functions but many people who
work with data immediately say well how
about Gaussian noise it has everybody
understands Gaussian noise really well I
understand the high dimensional
gaussians there are a lot of reasons for
wanting to do it it's more tightly
concentrated around its mean and so on
so when we relax to epsilon Delta
differential privacy we will be able to
use Gaussian noise and that's going to
help us a lot in accuracy yes
I want Delta to be negligible correct
epsilon we think of as a small constant
right yeah so I want to I wanted to use
um um crypto to simulate a trusted
center all right so we'll use
multi-party computation to do our car to
do everything that the trusted center
would have done there's some chance that
the adversary will manage to decrypt and
break privacy it's a small chance it's
negligible but that's the Delta
it's that possible that tiny probability
of distinguishing Gaussian noise also
permits some incredibly cool geometric
algorithms that was shown by Nick nickel
of taller and junk so today I'm going to
try to talk about these three things in
blue start with composition so I've been
a little hand weight yes concrete
intuition for that in some sense like
after X number of queries the adversary
will learn well we know from the
composition bounce for example that for
the original one that I mentioned early
on if our algorithm is epsilon
differentially private for one query and
we run it for K queries it'll be K
epsilon differentially private when K
epsilon gets uncomfortably large that's
privacy loss but you can also flip it
around and say if you want your
cumulative privacy lost to be epsilon
then run each of the individual queries
with privacy loss epsilon divided by K
and when you sum them up you'll get at
most epsilon that will give you less
accurate answers on the individual
queries but your cumulative losses good
what we're going to get now by the
relaxation is some well as the slide
says we're going to end up paying
something like root K rather than K
wait till the very very end of the talk
and if I have a and ask again if there's
time okay so okay so we need to say
really how are we formalizing
composition I've been kind of hand wavy
about it beyond multiple queries to the
same database I'd like to be able to
handle multiple adaptively and
adversarial generated databases and
mechanisms but the adversary generate
the pairs of adjacent data sets for
example I might like to answer questions
of the following form Bob go through
life he gets involved in say 10,000
databases if you were to have a lifetime
privacy cumulative privacy loss of
epsilon equals 1 what should be the
value of epsilon prime that is
guaranteed for each of the individual
databases so composition that we want to
be able to answer that well it canta to
Utley we're going to get a bound that
looks like this for all delta prime the
K fold composition after we define it of
epsilon 0 differentially private
mechanisms looks like this messy thing
we're going to talk about this messy
thing a lot but for now let me just
observe the following you can think of
it this way think of this as an expected
loss think of this as a standard
deviation and so what we're saying is
the probability that we're going to be T
standard deviations in Los away from our
expected loss is exponentially small in
T squared
and when you optimize in here it turns
out what this gives you is that your
cumulative lost looks something like
square root of K times epsilon rather
than K epsilon there's got to be a Delta
in there and that Delta is going to show
up here as a multiplier of log of 1 over
Delta so here's how we formalize things
this is like the left/right game of
ballare and someone remind me you guys
must know all right anyway so
we are going to play a game in which
let's say a curator is going to first
flip a coin get a value of zero or one
and then the adversary is going to do
the following the adversary will present
to the curator a pair of databases of
the adversaries choice this is the first
pair that's why the first index here is
one and a mechanism m1 the curator who
has fixed be once and for all we'll run
em one on the chosen element of the pair
and that's what the adversary gets to
see that outcome based on that the
adversary can choose a new pair of
databases and a new mechanism and then
our curator will run the new mechanism
on the selected element same day sorry
same be and so on and so forth and the
job of the adversary is just to figure
out what B is so for example when B
equals zero maybe this is the real world
and when B equals one we've gone through
and replaced all of Bob's data with
jungle and the adversaries job is trying
to figure out which of the two is the
case or I like to think in terms of
people and ghosts so and the adversary
is trying to figure out if Bob is a
person with real data or a ghost who has
no data so for the epsilon zero case the
group of which the proof of composition
relies on the fact that we prove that if
the privacy loss is bounded by epsilon 4
epsilon less than 1 then the expected
loss is bounded by epsilon squared
remember epsilon is less than 1 so the
expected loss is much smaller than the
worst-case loss so then what we do sort
of following along the lines of these
evolution of confidence arguments in
earlier work we model the cumulative
privacy loss as a martingale so we have
a bound on the maximum loss if it's an
epsilon differentially private algorithm
found on the maximum privacy loss is
guaranteed to be epsilon always and we
have a bound on the expected loss which
we prove and let's call the first
quantity a and the second one B and we
apply the zuma hosting lemma using the
fact that the privacy loss each step is
an independent independent founded
random variable and we get that the
probability that the cumulative loss is
off from its expectation this is
linearity of expectation is it most um
probability that this difference exceeds
Z times the square root of K times the
max loss is bounded by e to the minus Z
squared over 2
I'm not going to go through that proof
the proof of the expectation but I did
choose to put it into the slides for one
thing so that they're there for the
record that anybody can see them and
also to note that we're really looking
at a KL divergence notion here where you
as the distribution outputs when the
database is X and Z is the distribution
on outputs when the database is some
adjacent X Prime and so then we end up
proving something about the KL
divergence of two distributions that
that come from
the running of a differentially private
mechanism on adjacent data sets and
that's the whole proof you can see it's
not very long and you can look at it and
guy and I recently managed to get rid of
that factor of 2 which gives us actually
the right answer for randomized response
okay now what is it I oh and just let me
mention that the privacy that the
argument when Delta is not 0 first of
all the statement of the theorem is the
same except we have K times Delta here
so the deltas are adding up and the
argument is essentially the same as the
argument I gave you and it uses that
fact that I stated earlier that one
interpretation of epsilon delta
differential privacy is that with
probability 1 minus Delta the loss is
bounded by epsilon know him here's a
serious algorithm it's called the sparse
vector algorithm and it has proved to be
extremely useful and this I guess will
be the one real proof in the talk so we
have a database of size M and we're
looking at a collection of queries k of
them and k could be very large and
unlike the case with the small DB
algorithm where we use the exponential
mechanism to do the small database in
that case all of the queries were known
in advance but here the queries are
going to be presented in an online
fashion now
these queries are going to have a
certain property that is at most some
number C of them not too many are going
to said to be said to be significant
meaning that the the value of the query
when evaluated on the data set
significant means that that value
exceeds some fixed publicly known
threshold T and we can always enforce
this behavior by keeping track of how
many significant queries we've seen and
just quitting when we get up to and/or
see whatever the bound is so this is
what we're going to have and the goal
will be to find and optionally release
values for significant queries and pay
only for the significant queries so we
may have tons and tons and tons of
insignificant ones with just a couple of
significant ones and so what's being
produced is as output is insignificant
insignificant in significant significant
insignificant integrins at sigep so
that's what's being produced zeros and
ones insignificant 40 and 14 significant
so the way we're going to solve this
problem is we're going to first build an
epsilon zero differentially private
primitive that will halt when it has one
significant query so in this example
it'll run in here and it'll stop when it
here it's that first significant one and
then it will run it again and it will
stop here and what then will analyze the
cumulative loss using the composition
theorem
so here's our basic algorithm she is
that publicly known threshold we're
going to add noise to that threshold
scaled to two over epsilon and now we're
going to do the following for each query
we're going to compute F I of X when the
query fi is presented we're going to add
some nice random noise and we'll see if
that noisy noisy value exceeds the
threshold if so will output 1 and halt
because remember this is the little
building block where we're going to halt
at the first significant query in other
words without put 0 and repeat so it is
clear with the algorithm is the goal is
to identify the significant queries as
long as there aren't too many of them we
want to do it with differential privacy
so we are first going to build our
little epsilon zero differentially prime
private primitive that's this this is
going we're going to argue that it's
epsilon zero differentially private then
we'll apply composition utility will be
measured as follows if you're far from
the threshold then you must give the
right aunt you want to give the right
answer if you're close to the threshold
maybe you'll give the right answer maybe
we'll give the wrong answer so utility
is captured by the definition of close
and that we will call alpha
so consider some link k output we're
going to run this thing until it hits
the first significant query suppose that
happens to be the Keith query so what is
the output look like it looks like k
minus 1 0 indicating that the first K
minus 1 queries are insignificant
followed by a 1 indicating that the cave
1 is significant so we let G of X be the
maximum over the insignificant ones of
this value so we're going to fix all of
the random values except the cave one
and we're going to find G of X
accordingly so this is I'm assuming that
each of my individual functions fi has
sensitivity one so G of X will also have
sensitivity one so what is the
probability when the data set is X that
we actually produce this string that's
going to be the probability over the
noise that we introduced for the
threshold and the noise that we've
introduced for the cave query having
fixed the noises for queries one through
K minus 1 that that we get this behavior
which is just plugging in from the
algorithm it's the probability that the
threshold that we chose was bigger than
the max of everything from 1 to I minus
1 plus its noise and when we add noise
to the cave 1 we exceed the threshold
that just says this says we produce
zeros on the first K minus 1 and this
says we produce one on the cake so just
rewriting that just says that t hat is
in this interval know if we write this
out this is going to integrate over the
noise value for the cave query and
the noise the noisy value of t hat it's
the probability that we got this noise
times the probability that we got this
value for t hat times the indicator
function of that t hat that that t hat
is in this interval that's exactly
that's exactly what that said okay now
let's call this quantity star then we
define a change of variable so what do
we have going on here we have a change
of the max and we have a change of what
happens on the Keith query and these
could go in the wrong directions to make
things bad so we define these new
variables we applied the change of
variables and we get this just trust me
it's true this is from the previous
slide so when we take these together
what's going on here well I'm going to
take the probability that we got the hat
here and replace it by e to the epsilon
over 2 times the probability that we got
Z and notice that the hat minus V is
bounded by one so we use noise according
to sorry it's got to be bounded by two
if I wrote that so we use noise that was
bounded by for the plot for over epsilon
so we'll have a privacy loss of it most
epsilon over 20 right sorry this is why
you have it to get a 1 from here and a 1
from here and for the other term again
this is it most ETA epsilon over two
times that because t minus t hat has a
difference that's bounded by one and we
use the Laplace noise to over epsilon so
when we plug that in we get this and
this is this actually concludes the
proof we started with the probability
the a of X was equal to a and we have
here the probability that a of Y is
equal to a and they're different by this
multiplicative eat ooh the epsilon okay
so what happens under C fold composition
well if we used simple composition we
would get something like this for our
accuracy which has a see out here and if
we use epsilon differential prime exelon
Delta differential privacy we get this
square root of c times the log of 1 over
delta good so what do we use this for
well the most fantastic use of it is due
to heart and wrotham and and they want
to handle a lot of counting queries and
they want to handle a case where these
queries are coming online so what they
do is they take the multiplicative the
ordinary multiplicative weights update
algorithm I guess it was due to pluck in
tardo sh sh sh sh wasn't our toes and
they're going to have sort of one expert
for each element in the universe of
possible element and they're going to
essentially learn an approximation to
the database so they're going to
represent the database as a histogram
for all of the different kinds of people
in the universe for each kind how many
people of this kind are in the database
that's the count the histogram count for
that particular cell in the histogram so
you maintain a public distribution d on
the universe which is initially uniform
and when you're presented with a query
you first look at the value of this
query on this public distrib
d and it's going to give an estimate of
FI of X secret database now maybe it's
good estimate maybe it's complete crap
we don't know yet if it's good estimate
meaning that the absolute error is less
than some amount T then great we just
say hey you already know the answer
evaluated on that public distribution
and if it's not a good estimate I'm
going to add some fresh noise and and
and release an approximation to F I of X
and invoke the multiplicative weight
update rule on the public distribution
and of course these two lines in blue
they can be done by the curator they can
be done by the person who's using the
data set you don't need any secret
information to do the parts and blue so
what's going on in black what's going on
in black is basically sparse vector oh
you have a value that exceeded a
threshold hello and when that happens
you just do a simple counting query you
get the outcome and you proceed so
sparse vector lets you implement this
so what happens here we get down to what
happens with private multiplicative
weights if you did simple composition
then you would get a bound that is
similar to what you get in the blr blum
lligat and roth algorithm but if you use
epsilon delta differential privacy you
get an error that looks like this and
the key point and I'll talk about that
more in a moment the key point is that
and what heart and ratham show is that
the number of updates the number of
significant queries it looks only like
square out like in and so so that square
root of C becomes a square root of N and
that shows up there
this turns into isn't okay this is the
absolute error bound and look at what
happens when you have a universe where
each element is a less much less than d
squared dimension sorry n squared
dimensional object we're looking at the
fourth root so we end up with square
root of n here so we have a square root
of n here and a square root of n here
that's big that's an error that looks
like in but if you have the log of the
universe size the number of attributes
much less than n squared then you get
meaningful answers again and that's kind
of the best you can do so there's a very
discouraging result of bunawan and
vedang which says that any
differentially private algorithm that
accurately estimates d fractional
attribute means so these are basically
one-way marginals requires at most half
that has to have a number of data
records that's smaller than square root
of date ok and the prove uses
fingerprinting codes which were
introduced by Bonet and Shaw in the
context of traitor tracing so we're back
to traitor tracing and the particular
codes that they're using are due to
gábor takács when this business of just
asking for attribute means especially
when you're using the fingerprinting
codes of Tardos gives a distribution on
databases that's extremely natural and
that makes me unhappy of course because
i don't want negative results for very
natural sets of queries or natural sets
of databases and queries so this is bad
news it's just plain bad news
what's the vehicle result is just to
show you that you have to do something
is this is an unconditional result it's
yeah on the other hand okay so here's an
interesting question is it the case that
we expect the dimensionality of the data
to look like the square of the number of
records in the database there must be
lots of interesting settings in which
data are plentiful and that is not the
case you have zillions and zillions of
Records you would need zillions and
zillions of attributes squared weaseling
the zillions squared of attributes on
the other hand it's kind of interesting
I was reading a report from the National
Research Council on them I don't know
challenges of big data or whatever and a
few times in this report which has a
stellar set of authors there was a
reference to the assumption where the
belief that the number of attributes
grows linearly with the data set
linearly not quadratic I want to
investigate that further i read this
fairly recently but you know certainly
you can think of cases where the data
dimensionality is huge like genomes so
okay another application of epsilon
Delta differential privacy as I said is
that you can add Gaussian noise rather
than applause noise and the theorem
looks like this this is our old theorem
which said that to achieve epsilon zero
differential privacy you can add noise
that's scaled to this l1 norm difference
sensitivity and for the Gaussian you get
to look more like that you get to look
like the l2 norm so to achieve epsilon
Delta differential privacy you can add
noise that's normal with this variance
remember that this is the square of the
standard deviation so you end up with
Delta 2
square root log 1 over Delta as the the
expected size of your noise so 4k
arbitrary counting queries the l2
sensitivity is much smaller than the l1
sensitivity and it's a big win it's also
similar to what we get under advanced
composition and that is perhaps not an
accident so just bear with me for a
second just think about one dimensional
Gaussian because for high dimensions you
can reduce it to the one-dimensional
case using the spherical symmetry of the
distribution so suppose I'm adding noise
that's drawn from a Gaussian with
standard with variance Sigma squared and
I want the privacy loss to be bounded by
epsilon so I look at this ratio this is
what happens when the database is X this
is what happens when at the worst case
when this is some neighboring database
why and when we grind this through we
get that this this quantity is less than
epsilon basically whenever the draw has
met the draw from the noise sorry about
that calling it X is bounded by Sigma
squared epsilon over Delta F minus don't
have over to a great so using standard
tail bounds we can ensure that this
thing is met with probability at least
one minus Delta when we take Sigma
squared to have this size
now let's just take a closer look at
this let's not put that square root log
1 over Delta term into the standard
deviation for our noise and see what
happens so it's just plain no forget
that anyway let's look what happens as
long as this is the case the privacy
loss is bounded by epsilon what happens
outside this range we don't necessarily
get death and destruction probably air
draw from the Gaussian was just a little
bit larger because the Gaussian is very
tightly concentrated around its mean and
so most likely what happened to us was
that our privacy loss instead of being
potentially infinite is simply 2 epsilon
and in general we can argue that for the
Gaussian the probability that our
privacy losses at most T epsilon is
going to be something like 1 over te to
the minus t squared over 2 for all T in
other words when you're using the
Gaussian the privacy loss random
variable is itself a Gaussian which is
really cool because we understand it
very well we understand its behavior
under group privacy very well we
understand ssin trated around its mean
so you might remember the form in which
we expressed the composition bound we
looked at the probability of being T
standard deviations away from the mean
and we said that that was at most e to
the minus t squared over 2 so this is
very very similar T standard deviations
over oh wait t epsilons away e to the
minus t squared over 2 very similar so
this suggested a new characterization of
a kind of privacy which we call
concentrated differential privacy
and it has two parameters it has a mean
mu and it has well a standard towel and
the guarantee is something like this the
pipe the probability that your privacy
losses more than tea towels away is
bounded by e to the minus chi squared
formerly what we what we show is that
when we subtract a way we the way we
characterize it is by saying when we
subtract away the expected loss what we
are left with is what's called a sub
Gaussian random variable with standard
towel and the existence of a towel that
satisfies this for the moment generating
function is what defines a sub Gaussian
random variable so the nice things about
this our first of all it's more relaxed
than epsilon zero differential privacy
s10 says with probability zero your
primacy loss exceeds epsilon and as we
know the expected loss is still epsilon
squared at most epsilon squared what we
have now is that still the expected
losses at most epsilon squared but only
sort of graduated claims about the
chance that you're way far away from
that is very small this is more relaxed
notion it has nice group privacy and
interestingly if you look at the
behavior under composition of
concentrated differential privacy and
epsilon zero differential privacy and
also epsilon Delta it's all the same so
if you're doing many many studies you
can be much more relaxed about each
individual study and use concentrated
differential privacy instead of the pure
the epsilon Delta often simple well I
mean you showed one negative look is
there some simple mechanism right away
to use this concentrated differential so
this laplacian doesn't because it
specific to this epsilon actually any
epsilon zero differentially private
mechanism is what epsilon squared comma
epsilon differ um concentrated
differentially private and also the
Gaussian czar and so anything that you
build by combining those things any
complicated analysis that you built by
combining those things you can apply the
composition bounds that come naturally
for the sub calcium's and stay in this
concentrated form the convenient you
know just property but you know the
notion of epsilon differential privacy
already implies this cause analysis over
this case I mean there is a benefit of
analyzing directly this notion as
opposed to absolute differential privacy
because this looks like a more gradual
it's it's all I can say I don't think we
totally understand but what we do know
is it's more relaxed it should be more
flexible and and the way to think about
it is not for any individual mechanism
but some complicated analysis that's a
combination of little mechanisms
it lets you add less school by being
more relaxed and less demanding you can
get away with better accuracy right okay
another thing that we like about epsilon
Delta differential privacy suppose we
want to we have a data set and we'd like
to release an estimate of its medium so
for nice distributions this is typically
very stable know if there's okay but
maybe the data don't look at all like
they come from a nice distribution and
this could happen for two reasons one is
they don't come from a nice distribution
and another is they come from a nice and
distribution but this was an incredibly
weird draw you were just very very
unlucky when you created your data set
so here's an example of a data set that
um is really bad with respect to the
median when this yellow point is over
here this is the median if the yellow
point moves over to the left or anywhere
in here this will be the median so this
is bad the sensitivity of the median is
big in this case so what proposed test
release does is it's a way of trying to
be able to scale the noise to what you
seem Roscoe takova and Smith called the
local sensitivity for the median which
is the sensitivity of the median on this
particular database they had one way of
of achieving something like this which
they call smooth sensitivity and what
Jing and I dead is come up with a
basically a technique that lets us have
a quick and dirty way of doing this so
the idea is that for example you could
propose a local sensitivity and then you
can run a differentially private test
that says how far is this data set from
one whose local sensitivity is bigger
than s this is the sensitivity one query
right
if this database is 25 the addition of
25 different nodes away from something
whose local sensitivity is bigger than s
then a neighboring database will be at
most 26 away so we can ask this question
and if the response that we get back
says oh you're really far from a nasty
dataset then we just add noise that's
scaled to that s and we're fine now if
the noise was super weird like in fact
this data set has bad local sensitivity
it is distant zero from one whose local
sensitivity is bigger than s but the
response comes back oh it's very large
because when it did the draw from the
Laplace mechanism to answer this
question it just got a really bad result
really big positive result so that's a
super weird noise case I will call this
Delta of the nasty kind and we're
screwed maybe there is death and
destruction this is one of the reasons
we want Delta to be cryptographically
small of course so that we don't fall
into this so these guys do not give
concentrated differential privacy this
is the nasty version of epsilon Delta
but of course as cryptographers were
generally quite comfortable with the
idea of cryptographically small
probabilities of failure no
remember what else is in this talk
mention this work so so far most of the
time we've been talking about data sets
where the curator had our hands on all
of the data and then answers questions
sometimes the questions are presented as
a batch sometimes they're presented in
an online fashion but that's what's
going on but of course in real life you
might have other settings like streaming
settings so here we introduce the notion
of differential privacy under continual
observation so basically we're going to
look at algorithms that produce
observable outputs and every step and
the most natural this is a counter so we
say i don't know maybe you're counting
visits to a website or something so you
separate time into chunks and you want
to be able to you want your user to be
able to estimate at any time I how many
times the website was viewed
cumulatively in slots one through I so
here's our um what's going on you have
the algorithm has some state it sees the
first input it moves produces an output
moves your animation from million years
ago okay and so on no I didn't know how
to make things move yet okay so so um so
I'm going to describe a one kind of
privacy guarantee that you might want to
make which we call event level privacy
very very important to specify your
granularity of privacy for example if
you're creating a movie recommendation
system do you want to protect all of the
movies that guy watches or just one of
them right any individual movie that he
watched might be you might have privacy
for it but if there's a general theme
you might be able to detect it event
level is only promising tiny granularity
privacy not everything that somebody
might do
okay um and you can i'm just using this
as an example for this particular
algorithm so to capture time maybe we
can augment our universe with a symbol
of bottom so we would just say that two
strings are adjacent if there is a w on
sorry forget that line just forget it if
there is a W in the universe so that tau
can be obtained by replacing one
occurrence of W in sigma by bottom or
vice versa so i want an on button on
bottom element here so these guys are
going to be defined to be adjacent
inputs neighboring inputs okay so here's
a counter what we're going to do is
we're going to maintain counters for all
intervals of length powers of two so if
this is time here the time intervals
this is the interval consisting of the
first step the second step the third
step this interval is the first two
steps the second two steps and so on and
so forth and at the end of an interval
we're going to add so whenever we get a
completion here we're going to add some
fresh draw from Laplace distribution
with the appropriately chosen parameter
and publish the result and at any time I
to find to answer how many ones there
are in the count in steps one through I
we're going to find a union of at most
log total time is t disjoint segments
whose union is that interval interval
and we can use the binary representation
of I to do this and we just add noise
that's scaled to the log of T over
epsilon for privacy and then by a
Chernov style bound we get error that it
with high probability will be at most
something like log to the 1.5 t over
epsilon and in this version we needed t
in advance and I think Donna and her
co-authors have a version where you
don't need T in advance correct
okay so in general there's a really rich
algorithmic literature for differential
privacy there are also a lot of negative
results and complexity related results
and but here's an example here are some
examples of the kinds of things that
people know how to do now a lot of data
analysis tasks and there's also a book
that Aaron Roth and I wrote which is
available legally for free and on the
web so take a look but of course
differential privacy cannot be a panacea
the fundamental law that said overly
accurate estimates of too many
statistical queries is blatantly
non-private that still holds it's a
fundamental law I told you about it
before I told you anything about
differential privacy what we know is
that say concentrated differential
privacy can let us match at least one
instantiation of this law so as soon as
the law provides but in general general
they're they're open questions for
various kinds of queries it is a pennis
it is not a panacea so in my last few
minutes I want to talk about some
applications of differential privacy
that actually have nothing to do with
privacy none whatsoever so this is
differential privacy in the service of
other goals here's a paper by mallesh pi
and error rough and it's a it's about
algorithmic mechanism design not our
kind of mechanisms but the economics
kinds of mechanisms and they point out
that differential privacy provides a
powerful tool kit for controlling the
stability of mechanisms in general which
yields a set of tools for designing
novel mechanisms even economic settings
completely unrelated to privacy
so this
another example in game theory this is a
brand new one differential privacy
offers just the right tool it requires
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah they
use just the existence of a
differentially private algorithm for in
order to argue whatever it is they argue
so this is the fact that there exists
differentially private algorithms that
are now having implications in game
theory and I'll tell you about one more
application which we call correctness
protection in adaptive data analysis
you've probably all heard of the paper
that most publish results are false and
there are a lot of efforts to control
false discovery in science there's a
famous Binyamin Ian Hawke Berg's
algorithm and a huge literature that
followed from that for controlling
what's called the false discovery rate
in multiple hypothesis testing I assume
that you all have an intuitive idea of
what this is but you know these are the
results that's sort of false we say no
drinking coffee is really bad for you
when in fact it turns out to be really
good for you we here recently or
whatever um in order to address some of
these things the community has has come
up with other techniques like
sophisticated cross validation
techniques or the use of holdout sets
for checking conclusions that you learn
on trading data and validate them on the
on the holdout set people do things like
pre-registering the hypotheses that
they're going to test and so on but most
of the theory is actually for the static
case when sort of the questions are all
known in advance their fixed and science
is by nature and adaptive process and
this famous statistician took you said
that we often forget how science and
engineering function ideas come from
previous exploration more often than
from lightning strokes
in other words the second question you
ask does depend on the outcome of the
first question the second study or the
case study that you run depends on the
outcomes of the first k minus 1 studies
it's fundamentally adaptive we're over
in some sense it's going to get worse
normally what you would do when you want
to have a new study is you'd go off and
you'd recruit a new data set and work on
the new data set you'd have fresh
samples but what may happen now instead
is that people will be working with some
canonical data sets some canonical very
very large data sets and it won't be
feasible at all to go out and recruit
another fresh set of data just
absolutely not possible everybody will
be working from the same set so it's a
sort of accuracy problem in the land of
plenty we had privacy in the land of
plenty where we had good answers this is
an accuracy problem so let's go back to
our formulation what are we worried
about here's how we started in a very
formal way the analyst asks a question
from the database gets an answer asks
another question gets an answer and
everything was adaptive is adaptive so
the question that's asked at the ISTEP
depends on the previous i minus 1
answers our worry is that the analyst
will find a query for which the database
is not representative of the population
and will say hey I have this great new
discovery it's something that has been
over fit to the actual data set and what
we're going to what we argue is that
differential privacy actually
neutralizes the risks that are incurred
by a DAP tivity in other words in our
way of thinking it's hard to find a
query for which the data set is not
representative and I know that's
confusing and I'm just going to give you
a little bit of intuition it's the end
of a long week so let's fix a query q in
advance no data had been collected yet
what fraction of the population is over
6 feet tall now you're going to go out
and you're going to sample the
population and you're going to come up
with a pretty big sample and you know
that almost any big sample is going to
give you a good estimate for this
that's why statistics works so in our
language most data sets are
representative most large data sets are
representative with respect to this
query go out find a data set you're
likely to get a good answer an answer
that's representative of the population
as a whole now suppose in the process of
adaptive exploration the analyst came up
with a query for which the data set is
not representative then in some really
concrete sense she learned something
significant about the data set if it
doesn't happen when she didn't already
interact with the data set it does
happen when she does interact with the
data set then she learned something from
the data set something has changed so
very intuitively preserving the data of
the privacy of the data may prevent this
kind of overfitting and that intuition
turns out to be correct so there there
are known connections between notions of
the stability of a learning algorithm
and its ability to generalize I
mentioned this very early on when we
were just defining privacy in the first
place and saying why our notion might
give us utility and the stability
notions that were considered in Prior
works don't compose but differential
privacy composes that's they said that's
where all of the power is so this gives
us a calculus or a toolkit for building
up complex algorithms that status I
stability guarantees that turn out to be
sufficient to give generalizability now
if you present this to someone who works
with data they'll say ok get lost in we
have our way of working with the data we
don't want to do anything a
differentially private fashion Vanessa
knows this is true um you know down with
differentially private interference okay
so err answered this is go ahead make my
day so what do I mean by this say work
on the training data set the way you
have always worked on training on your
data so
take your data randomly partition it
into hold out and training and then do
everything you used to do on the
training set just as you did before but
when you think you've come up with an
interesting conclusion you are going to
test it on the holdout set the way
you've always done before except not
you're going to interact with the
holdout set in a differential a private
way so learn on the training set chick
against the holdout via a differentially
private mechanism and the key point here
is that what you can argue is that
differential privacy ensures that your
future exploration you know maybe the
holdout set says yes you have a valid
conclusion maybe it says no your
conclusion is not either way if you went
back to the hold out without having used
differentially private access to the I'm
sorry when you go back to your training
set if you had not used differential
privacy then your questions have been
contaminated by the holdout set and they
won't be independent of a holdout set
what differential privacy does is it
essentially says if you've accessed the
holdout set in a differentially private
way then your subsequent queries are
intuitively roughly speaking independent
of the holdout set so you can use it
again it's a reusable hold out set the
ability to reuse is no how would we do
it well one case that we've analyzed
uses statistical queries again those
counting queries how many people in the
database satisfy property P and you guys
know from the learning theory literature
that statistical queries are very
powerful as a learning mechanism and
we're going to interact our interaction
with the holdout set will be through the
sparse vector technique that you've
heard about so when you think you found
something interesting some predicate
that's really interesting you estimate
you know you compute what is the
fraction of the training set that has
that
predicates and then you go in in a
differentially private way you learn
what is the fraction and you learn
whether the difference between the
fraction on the holdout and the fraction
on the training exceeds a threshold is
whether whether the difference exceeds a
threshold or not that is a sparse vector
question and so you can officially
handle exponential in the size of the
holdout many queries tolerating up to
the square of the holdout set size of
failed validations okay so conclusion
privacy-preserving data analysis is a
problem that's been studied for at least
50 years differential privacy is a
general solution concept and its robust
to the networked world there's a lot of
work going on in different areas
programming languages formal methods
signal processing statistics blah blah
blah blah blah even law and as of this
time there is still no competing theory
of privacy preserving data analysis but
the approach also tells us fundamental
something fundamental about computing
with stability we have a general
technique for statistical validity in
adaptive data analysis and we've seen
that it's also being useful in other
fields like economics and game theory so
it is talking about computation in some
deep way and it's very exciting to me to
try to understand
so this is Marvin comment in the in
yours picking up the most popular hobby
model I don't think it's actually that
unlikely that the wrong one will come
out on top because of the noise is
independent for each respondent then the
noise standard deviation is on the
orders so actually no it won't be on the
order of root end because we're using
the Laplace stories and the Laplace
noids is being scaled to 1 over epsilon
or you can think about it in terms of
the exponential mechanism so what
happens is if there is a decent gap
epsilon is really small yes nonetheless
we tend to think of epsilon as a
constant and we tend to think of n is
very large we usually think in terms of
internet scale data sets but you're
right with small data sets it would the
noise could be very bad and specific
bounds you can get from the exponential
mechanism like even if you don't get the
very best you might get one of the most
a hobby which is among the most popular
if there's a big gap between some
popular ish ones and the others it would
you know that
it would well you can't rank the less
popular movies this way because then
this is just a technique for answering
what is the most popular there's quite
an interest in saying what happens what
about top K and I can refer you to a
paper that talks about that but
typically you'll end up paying square
root of K factor for that you think
you're whoops I mean hello interested
more in politics and what's used in the
real world right now so do you think the
differential privacy scanning was close
to telling the input that you would like
to tell so for people to change their
way so I don't know what the status what
is the status that's a really good
question and I'm not current on
everything but I would say there's this
sort of wave happening of more and more
people who are getting to the point of
implementing we're trying to implement
so we're sort of on this uptick right
now and I don't know what's going to
happen I simply don't know yet well I
mean
oh yeah possibly into a private party on
to some of these data database or some
there are some remedies on the database
itself not only the approach I'm not
sure I'm not sure exactly what you mean
by she has some certain probably to be
sure differential privacy is a
worst-case guaranteeing which means that
however it is that you may you get your
data sets it still works and so if
they're probabilistic it'll still work
predicting on the next step and this in
this case I mean can we apply DP on do
it so if I understand your question
correctly which i'm not sure up i think
the answer is yes the guy do you think
the answer is yes depressingly the woof
we have some remedies on the database or
data set yourself so as Cynthia was
saying a guarantee of differential
privacy is a worst-case guarantee it
doesn't matter where your data is coming
from differential privacy works perhaps
what you're asking is can you use the
noise that's inherent in the data from
the generation process in order to get
prizes have one I have one comment about
that so Abhishek Obama canned i looked
at the question of whether you could use
database turn so people come and they
leave from the database and that
provides certain it provides some
uncertainty if you assume that the
adversary just can't know who all is
joining and leaving the database they
could know something but not too much
about it and it's unbelievably worse
than you'd think it would be
unfortunately maybe other people can
come up with better models of turn that
are still realistic but but give better
bounce but unfortunately the results
were quite negative
because that because I came out before I
think the difference from correctness is
that here you are as in cryptography
we're thinking about an adversary was
trying to learn something about you and
this adversary might go to some lengths
to understand more about the process
that the data came from than just what
your model is guaranteeing so we really
are thinking about adversaries as we are
in cryptography and so it's hard to just
assume that the data is random and no
one knows people know very little about
it that's I think a lot weird the
hardest comes from it was just really
awful even without anything that
complicated sigh there's privacy you
have a way to guide the statistician in
the process of collecting the data did
you say of collecting or correcting
vision starts from something that he
wants to study in a whole world of
populations there to choose for in order
to collect the data for studying that
problem does have the differential
privacy privacy too is useful for in
that aspect of where do i go to collect
the data for for my study I don't know
the answer that question um in a
differential privacy is something that
we use on a data set so think of the
entire universe as your data set now and
then there is something about which
where you access it maybe I don't know
it's a very intriguing question i'm
sorry i don't know the answer okay any
very interesting any other questions
scrapping methods and differential
practice so that I see the haven't Smith
is already written a paper about that um
so I look kind of be approach of
applying differential privacy for
hypothesis testing something that under
the assumption that bootstrapping is
differentially private is in fact
something that gets stunned surprisingly
often in house data in the physical
sciences so I don't know I guess this is
a comment and not a question but um okay
right so it sort of passes close to two
things first of all the question of
whether you can do differentially
private control of the false discovery
rate is a really interesting one and
recently wei jia su li zhong and I came
up with such an algorithm which to our
knowledge is the first such algorithm
and I'm pretty excited about it but so
that's something I'm false discovery but
on the bootstrapping and this is not a
heuristic this is a real algorithm with
me approvable FDR control guarantees the
bootstrapping um I think we're going to
see more than just the first paper from
Adam and glad he wrote it but there's I
think that this is really interesting
and there are some variants that you
might want to do like bag of little boot
straps that that could be very cool in
this context but I've been working on
that recently with them oh god terrible
to blank on your co-authors name
and can you help make you remember the
summer is PESA okay anyway sorry anyway
it's very interesting and i look forward
to lots of people looking at at
bootstrapping in this in this setting
absolutely follow is it grace what your
current work / results fine since we
don't have a proof yet we just don't
have I can't call it a result but I'm
looking forward to that thank you again